South Korea is offering the first
high-level talks with North Korea in
more than two years the overnight offer
comes in response to a New Year's speech
by North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
he said he's considering sending a
delegation to next month's Winter
Olympics in South Korea in the same
speech kin made new threats against the
u.s. saying quote the entire United
States is within range of our nuclear
weapons major Garrett is at the White
House with the challenge confronting
president Trump major good morning good
morning president Trump returned here
from Florida Monday facing more hot
rhetoric from North Korea and a burst of
anti-government demonstrations in Iran
there is no clear path to resolve the
former or capitalize on the latter
president Trump's arrival after dark
Monday at the White House came as North
Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon marked the
new year with more nuclear threats heck
dong Xuan eskimos its own Kim claimed to
have a nuclear button on his desk and
warned that all of the US mainland is
within striking distance we'll see we'll
see the president reacted cautiously at
his New Year's Eve bash at mar-a-lago
telling guests adversaries should take
notice
[Applause]
if we blink god help us all on Face the
Nation South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham Warren 2018 could be a year of
quote
extreme danger 2018 is going to be the
year to deny North Korea the capability
to hit the homeland sanctions will never
work completely without the threat of
credible military force in Iran violent
protests calling for political change
entered their fifth day the president
reacted on Twitter writing Iran is
failing at every level and claiming the
Iranian people are repressed and hungry
for food and for freedom Graham says the
administration needs to develop a
clearer strategy on Iran
you just can't tweet here you have to
lay out a plan the president must decide
later this month whether to reimpose
economic sanctions on Iran that were
lifted in 2015 as part of the Iran
nuclear deal
beyond a big decision for the president
major thank you